et comme chaque mardi soir nous
retrouvons adrien labit bonsoir adrien
mon sport mathieu et votre invité cette
semaine
raphaël cheilan berger vous êtes alors
maire de wattwiller mais surtout nouveau
conseiller départemental du canton de
cerner bonsoir bonsoir
adrien wii ou nous avez vous emmener
cette semaine alors hier j'étais en
compagnie d'annie claude n va chez elle
m'a emmené chez elle dans les hautes
vosges
nous nous sommes donc rendus dans un
lieu emblématique du canton la station
du markstein où malgré l'absence de
neige j'ai pu faire de la luge mais ce
n'est pas tout car le nouveau canton
concerné c'est un territoire extrêmement
divers
regardez au pied du markstein et du
grand ballon c'est en le canton de
cerner territoire de charme et
l'histoire ici la terre garde le
souvenir douloureux de la grosne hier
entre 1915 et 1916 le vieil armand fut
la dernière demeure de 30 mille jeunes
français et allemands autre mémoire
celle de l'industrie textile qui fit
vivre la vallée pendant deux siècles
avant de s'éteindre activité s'est
déplacé à l'entrée de la vallée thann et
cernay situe à la croisée des axes de
communication est ouest et nord sud
accueille une industrie diversifiée dans
ce secteur où les communications sont
intenses
le conseil départemental envisage des
aménagements routiers autour de vieux
thann c'est un projet qui matures depuis
quelques temps et qui a un double
objectif d'une part de délester la route
nationale 66 qui tout le monde le sait
est saturé à certaines heures du jour
mais également de desservir la zone
d'activités économiques de vieux thann
et anne le réseau routier est un enjeu
important d'autant qu' on a quand même
près de 25 mille véhicules jour au
niveau du verrou de thann
c'est effectivement un enjeu parce qu'il
est handicapant pour le développement
économique du fond de la vallée si le
département investit dans le réseau
routier
l'agriculture n'est pas en reste en 2006
l'abattoir de cerner a ouvert ses portes
financée par les fonds départementaux
cette infrastructure permet de
structurer la filière dans toute la
vallée
cet abattoir qui est dédié aux circuits
courts circuits de proximité a permis
non seulement à hauteur de montagne mais
aussi du second volet de la plaine
d'alsace
à avoir une certaine crédibilité dans ce
qu'on appelle les circuits courts on ne
peut pas concevoir promouvoir des
circuits coup ci n'a pas de d'abattage
de proximité au travers de ce milieu
agricole
on a un double impact on a un impact
environnemental fort sur la beauté de
nos paysages et on a un impact
économique est très fort également lieu
de travail des agriculteurs les pentes
du massif font aussi le bonheur des
touristes
en 2001 la station de ski du markstein
était au bord du dépôt de bilan
dans le cadre de sa politique montagne
le département a investi pour la sauver
on a racheté les équipements on a remis
à niveau les remontées mécaniques et on
a fait toute une série d'actions au
niveau des pistes de ski qui ont quand
même permis d'améliorer les conditions
de ski n'a fait la l'amélioration du
stade de slalom aussi parce qu'il faut
savoir que le markstein est une station
à vocation sportive nous si familiale
est la dernière création c'est la piste
de luge sur rail qui remplace un ancien
bob luge qui était complètement obsolète
et dangereux on a de l'ambition pour le
site on a beaucoup d'ambition maintenant
il faudra qu'on arrive à calais nos
ambitions par rapport aux possibilités
financières encore existantes mais
l'ambition c'est fonctionnement annuel
pour le markstein fille les pistes de
ski n'ouvre que quelques mois par an le
sommet fait toute l'année
le bonheur des randonneurs et des
amateurs de parapente alors retour en
plateau avec raphaël berger alors vous
êtes le benjamin de l'assemblée
départementale
vous êtes aussi le maire de wattwiller
vous avez seulement 25 ans pourquoi se
lancer dans une carrière politique si
jeune je crois qu'on choisit pas de se
lancer dans une carrière politique on
choisit de s'engager en politique de
s'engager sur des mandats pour le coup
locaux c'est quelque chose la vie
publique m'a toujours interpellé jeunes
lycéens puis étudiant on a vu tout à
l'heure dans le reportage un jeune
lycéen qui s'engageait voilà c'est une
première forme d'engagement et pour moi
elle a débouché en 2014 sur
une liste aux élections municipales on
arrête on a eu la chance de gagner les
élections municipales et puis de fil en
aiguille les élections cantonales ont
suivi l'année suivante et puis dans le
canton de cernay y avait cette
opportunité avec annick de monter un
tandem qui a bien fonctionné qui
fonctionne bien au quotidien dans le
travail et je crois que c'est d'abord
l'envi de faire l' envie d'apporter une
nouvelle façon de faire qui qui motive
l'engagement d'un jeune en politique
alors c'est un canton qui a été
redécoupée d'ailleurs comme tous les
tous les autres dans la région avec un
envoi vraiment un
une dichotomie en pleine montagne et du
coup c'est quoi ces il faut en faire une
cohérence il faut en faire un atout
alors que c'est quand même de problèmes
aux deux territoires sur lesquels on
retrouve des problématiques qui peuvent
être assez différentes
je partage pas tout à fait votre votre
analyse le canton a été redécoupée il
est grand un c'est le deuxième plus
grand canton du département du haut rhin
on n'est pas loin de 50 2000 habitants
juste après saint louis il sait pas pour
autant qu'il n'est pas cohérent parce
qu'il suit le fil de la vallée de la
thur donc on a on à la vallée de la thur
de son aveu de son amont jusqu'à son
aval et c'est intéressant je pense en
terme de
deux visions politiques du territoire
parce que ça permet d'organiser la
solidarité entre le fond de la vallée on
a tendance à dire le début de la vallée
où il ya des habitants qui sortent
parfois pour travailler qui travaillent
sur place où on a une bouffée d'oxygène
on a vu des images du markstein qui sont
absolument remarquable on a des zones de
loisirs assez importantes qui sont
concentrés dans cet espace là et puis le
débouché de la vallée qui est vraiment
au croisement entre deux axes de
circulation majeur qui concentre une
forte présence industrielle avec un taux
de production de richesses à c'est un
progrès important et ça permet vers
vraiment aussi d'organiser la solidarité
dans ce territoire cohérent
voilà alors justement vous l'avez
rappelé la situation favorable de thann
et de cernay
c'est justement c'est ça rend plus
facile d'attirer des entreprises chez
vous cette situation
historiquement la vallée de la thur est
un territoire attractif pour les
entreprises
aujourd'hui on a le tram train si on a
aujourd'hui le tram train dans la vallée
de la thur c'est le premier tram-train
qui a été construit en france c'est
aussi une des vallées dans laquelle on a
eu un des premiers trains de france
parce qu'il y avait une industrie
textile notamment dans la vallée qui
était qui étaient très présentes que
autour du cours d'eau autour de cet axe
de communication qui traverse les vosges
est qui et qui rejoint le benelux on
avait des échanges commerciaux
importants et ces échanges existent
toujours encore c'est vrai que les
contraintes aujourd'hui en matière de
déplacements d'acs sur routiers font
plutôt que les industries les grosses
industries cherchent à s'installer dans
le débouché de la vallée mais il ya
encore de l'industrie dans la vallée et
je crois que c'est
notre notre mission de conseiller d'un
territoire de s'engager pour que le
travail se répartissent sur l'ensemble
du territoire parce que si on a des
problèmes aujourd'hui de circulation
dans la vallée c'est lié au fait que les
gens sortent de la vallée pour
travailler et rentra nouvelle soir s'ils
sont dans la vallée pour travailler il
ya tout un flux de véhicules qu'on évite
donc je crois que notre mission est
aussi de rendre attractif la vallée pour
l'installation des entreprises
les vans exemples étonnants justement
d'ailleurs dans le reportage juste avant
c'est le cet abattoir que le département
a contribué à financer c'est le genre
d'exemple étonnant presque insolite sous
le département d un des leviers pour
pour soutenir ce genre de projet
justement va fixer des fils et des
emplois dans la vallée l'enjeu de
l'abattoir il était essentiel pour tout
le département du haut rhin il a été
construit à cerner mais il a un impact
sur sur la vallée notamment
l'agriculture parce que c'était une des
problématiques majeures de l'agriculture
haut rhinoise notamment les lieux en fin
de l'élevage haut rhinois il n'y avait
pas d'avs n'y avait pas d'abattage qui
rendait difficile et les circuits courts
aujourd'hui on favorise les circuits
courts d'ailleurs le département du
haut-rhin mène une politique ambitieuse
en matière de circuits courts dans ses
propres cantine mais si la chaîne n'est
pas complète
dans le département on peut
difficilement parler de circuits courts
et cet abattoir c'était 1-1
c'était un maillon de la chaîne qui
était incontournable
et la voilà c'était un levier important
du département avec une investissements
financiers conséquents mais qui
aujourd'hui fonctionne et qui
aujourd'hui rend bien service à
l'agriculture de montagne bien sûr mais
aussi à l'élevage qu'on peut retrouver
dans le piémont ou dans la plaine
alors on l'a également vu dans le
reportage le hartmannswillerkopf un haut
lieu de mémoire de la première guerre
mondiale
c'est dans votre canton comment on fait
pour garder cette mémoire vivante c'est
dans mon canton et puis en plus c'est
dans ma commune en grande partie puisque
il ya plusieurs projets au
hartmannswillerkopf j'ai accueilli en
août dernier les deux présidents le
président de la république française et
le bund ce président de la république
fédérale d'allemagne eurent kings pour
une pour une cérémonie franco allemande
au sommet du hartmannswillerkopf on voit
là les images du secrétaire d'état
mais plutôt des chimiques est venue la
semaine dernière on a la chance que la
première guerre mondiale soit sous les
feux de la rampe pendant pendant les
quatre 4 années qu'on vit là avec le
centenaire de la guerre mondiale mais il
ya des initiatives à avoir aujourd'hui
un gros projet de construction d'un
historial qui permettra d'être une forme
de centre interprétative de la première
guerre mondiale parce qu'aujourd'hui
cent ans après ma génération dont même
dont les parents n'ont pas connu la
guerre seuls les grands parents et
encore la mémoire s'éloigne on a du mal
à comprendre quel était le conflit entre
la france l'allemagne
on a du mal à comprendre quels étaient
les enjeux de se battre au sommet des
vosges pourquoi aller se battre au
hartmannswillerkopf quand on vient sur
site aujourd'hui quelle échéance
ça va peut espérer voir sortir sa dot s
si tout va bien le mémorial devrait être
inauguré au deuxième semestre 2010 est
et ce sera là vraiment un espace de
compréhension de ce conflit qui sera à
destination de la jeunesse franco
allemande pour comprendre là pourquoi
l'allemagne et la france sont battus
pour quoi ils se sont battus là bas
pourquoi ils se sont battus sur les vols
et pourquoi aujourd'hui la construction
européenne a tellement de sens
malgré tout le débat politique polémique
qu'on peut avoir sur l'intégration de la
zone euro etc
nous on est en alsace on est au coeur de
l'europe et c'est important d'avoir des
outils pour transmettre cette histoire
aux générations à venir